[Music]
years of public service means like
recycle ranks help push recycle recycle
Rex okay but many people have been doing
this recycling thing totally wrong cross
contamination with trash now threatens
the industry China the world's biggest
buyer of recycled materials stopped
importing a lot of our salvaged goods
last year because they were too
contaminated that prompted some
communities to end their recycling
programs while others cut back on the
types of items they accept Tony Duke
opal is here to show us which items in
our homes cannot be salvaged and how to
do it right Tony good morning good
morning Salvage is such a gentle word
what we're really talking about here is
what to toss out and what not to toss
out and on that subject tell me if this
sounds familiar you're in your kitchen
and you're not sure if something can be
recycled or not but you toss it in the
bin anyway that is called wish cycling
and it's gotten so bad that the industry
says an average of 25 percent of
recycling is now actually trash hard to
believe I know but we saw it for
ourselves how you doing I'm Tony I work
for CBS News Oh
we were doing a story about recycling
and so I have a very weird question to
ask you you please take a look at your
residing on a recent day in Orlando
three brave souls agreed to haul out
their recycling bins one two three and
let us take a peek inside with the help
of Mitch headland from recycle across
America each bin contained items that at
best or questionable this is an obvious
one
definitely when it has food waste in you
could rinse that and it would be better
so in most communities you wouldn't be
able to recycle it our pot corrects
cardboard
yes but normally it needs to be broken
down with many things that should have
gone straight to the trash this is a
total no no styrofoam this cannot be
recycled in your community whatever the
chip bag is that's a problem yeah this
is a problem here yes is recyclable but
not this kind of paper paper does look
like it was a good dinner oh that's good
intention but so not recyclable and so
dangerous paper towels and napkins and
tissue are not recyclable this
altogether might lead to all of
everything that you've done and you've
put good effort towards the whole thing
going to landfill
now before you judge know the errors we
caught here and that's your souvenir
thank you are being repeated across
America just in general recycling can be
so confusing that people just don't take
it seriously and if you've ever wondered
where all that recycling ends up there's
a good chance it's at a sorting facility
like this one owned by waste management
24 hours a day five days a week its
workers are catching all our mistakes
nice to meet you Mike Taylor oversees
recycling operations here in Elkridge
Maryland
he showed us what happens to the
materials we put on the curb so where
are we in the process right now we call
this the presort belt and these
hard-working men and women are looking
for the items that shouldn't be in the
system in the first place
workers here target what they call
Tanglers which can get caught up in the
sorting equipment things like plastic
bags coat hangers and garden hoses other
recycling programs refuse items like
yogurt cups and shampoo bottles what
should not be in the recycling we
shouldn't have the plastic film in in
our recycling operation here
we don't like toil no boiled egg carton
egg carton the styrofoam egg carton
isn't part of the program is that
recyclable there's another one when in
doubt throw it out when in doubt throw
it out easy who came up with this phrase
when in doubt throw it out we actually
started that Mitch headlands
organization is trying to remove all
doubt recycle across America advocates
for standardized labels on both home and
public recycling bins spelling out
exactly what can be recycled in each
community the labels in use here in
Orlando and coming soon to other cities
may be our best hope for pulling
recycling out of the dumps if the public
is willing to do it and we have the
infrastructure in place to do it then
the industry and municipalities oh it to
all of us to make sure it's easy for us
to do right and the reason this is such
a big deal is China now turns down any
recycling that's not 99.5% pure
uncontaminated material so check your
labels check with your local recycler
and get it right otherwise it might go
straight to a landfill oh yeah wish
cycler your everybody is that lady
little sad when you were pointing out
all the mistakes also the belt was
moving so fast to me how could they get
all the stuff they get as much as they
can look at the bottom line the takeaway
is when in doubt throw it out and you
want to recycle right because recycling
is really popular 94% of people do at
least some of the time yeah some people
I've heard have battles at home about
whether something should recycle or not
and so if you're on the side of you know
I'm gonna throw it out anyway you're on
the right side of history are you can
win arguments with your family members
you're on the right side if you throw it
out you know this about some people I
have like John Dickerson is just gonna
clip and save that and put it on a loop
in the different household work thank
you although I know it's a stinky
assignment it was alright for more tips
on what you should and should not do
with recycling check out our Facebook
page later this morning
Mitch headland from recycle across
America will joan tony for a live chat
on why americans should not give up on
recycling and i don't know why this just
popped in my head but i think it would
be really funny to go to Gail's house i
don't take it out of your funny we were
ringing the doorbell okay and tomorrow
on CBS this morning we'll have an inside
recycling center look from oregon that's
all coming up
[Music]